chris is with us in Oklahoma City hi
Chris how are you very are you better
than I deserve what's up okay
essentially I am in college and I'm the
treasurer of my fraternity and I've been
kind of known to be good with money
so I've guys constantly coming to me and
asking me questions how do I talk to
them about being better with their
finances because I have people telling
me about how they're paying for trips of
student loans or they're buying a $2,000
TV with a new credit card they got how
do I talk to people and convince them
not to make these bad decisions are
these people and the ones that are
asking you or yeah yeah they come to me
they talk to me about it and I just
don't know how to deal with it because
you know I I tell them my opinion I tell
them what I do with my money
and I do exactly what you say and they
just I I don't understand why and people
make the decisions that they do and I
don't know how to help them make better
decisions okay
yes well so when they come to you're
saying this guy will use the example the
TV okay so he came to you after he did
that or he came to you ask you if he
should do that we was talking to me
about it
and he was saying about how he's looking
at buying a new $2,000 TV and things
like that they're not necessarily asking
me for advice but I talked home and I
want to give them advice and say hey you
shouldn't do that how do I do that well
I mean the biggest problem you got in a
situation like that is if they're not if
someone's not asking your advice this
including my friends and I'm freaking
Dave Ramsey okay I think right you know
my grandmother's saying applies those
convinced against their will or of the
same opinion still I mean I had a friend
of mine Lisa car the other day and he
came to show me his new car that he just
leased all right I mean and you know you
know Dave Ramsey hates leases right I
mean he knows that so I mean he really
wasn't asking my opinion and there's no
sense of me hammer and the guy I just
said hey nice new car I'm proud you got
your car whatever I mean there's no
sense in me doing that because a he's
not listening obviously he's not going
to follow what I'm saying he just wanted
to show them
his new car and I'm like there's no
reason to you know to try to fix that
afterwards now if you're looking at a
guy he's thinking about buying a new TV
all you can do just say okay so you're
borrowing money on a student loan to buy
a TV when you say that out loud
does that sound smart to you that's a
question I would ask him because it
doesn't sound smart when you say it out
loud it sounds ridiculous and I don't
care how great next up you are or in
mature you are if you say that out loud
I'm borrowing money on a student loan to
buy a TV if you say that phrase out loud
you have to look in the mirror and go
that's dumb I mean really if you got it
right you know so you just say does that
really sound smart because I don't think
it does and I wouldn't do that I think
you're going to get yourself into a mess
here and you know you're gonna repay on
their student loan for a long time after
you forgot where that television is and
it'll be in landfill somewhere at some
point because it's outmoded and updated
but you can't convince people against
their will if you can get ask them
questions and get them moving in a you
know in a direction to have a common
sense thing but sometimes they're not
they're just kind of there to announce
their stupidity like my friend you know
it's like hey I just leased a car well
you know he's just announcing a
stupidity and there's nothing you can do
without a you know at any age you can
only convince people if you have an
entree into their thing into their life
and what I would suggest is if you can
get them to ask you well what do you
think oh now we've got something going
on right because at that point you know
you just you asked me and that's kind of
the way the shuttle operates right
people call up and they they ask me and
so I'm obligated then to help them and
to tell them the right thing to do but
if someone I'm just walking along the
street and somebody's doing something
dumb it's not my job to stop and
interrupt them besides that it's not
very effective I can't get them to not
do things so some of them are going to
do what they're going to do they some of
them just want to announce their
stupidity others really here starting to
they're saying it out loud because
they're considering that this might be
dumb I would ask them questions and ask
them something like hey say that out
loud again I'm going to say I'm going to
borrow money
a student loan to buy television does
that sound smart when you say that
because man you just kind of laugh
because they would go no it's not smart
well then don't do it I mean it's dumb
and so really really dumb you see while
we have a student loan problem people
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]